great so welcome everyone
to this uh virtual meetup
22nd pi data cambridge meetup um
so yeah we've been going on for some
time and we're doing virtual meetups
now in these last months of course
because it's been
uh because of the circumstances uh with
the pandemic
uh so we have a great agenda today
so we've got an intro we have this intro
slides
and we have uh speakers from our one of
our sponsors fetch ai so it's an
introduction to the decentralized
delivery network
ddn by josh anders and we also have
a speaker from decoded why
battery-powered iot data acquisition is
hard which both of them should be really
exciting
so who we are so we are paid at
cambridge which is our local cambridge
uh
uk meetup we started in november 2018
and we do monthly meetups and we do this
every last wednesday of the month
uh this is organized by me federico uh
joris leandro and ole so in this call i
believe only ole and me are
at this time but we're always uh here to
help you out with anything
dealing with the meetup and of course
we are uh our parent kind of company
charity is new focus and essentially
noon focus
is is all about you know open code to
create better science so it supports a
lot of
the libraries that you might be doing in
data science
with doing data data stuff in python and
other languages
and pi data itself is an educational
program of new focus
uh so they support us for example
us being able to have this webinar on
zooms
to be able to have what we the the
infrastructure on meetup
that's how in a way they sponsor this
meetup and but we are an educational
programmer
so as i said before there's many
libraries that
new focus support some of them you can
see on the left
i personally use numpy uh
maplo led jupiter but there's many
others
that many of you can use
so yeah uh i would personally ask you if
you would uh
consider donating to noon focus uh these
with the pandemic normally noon focus uh
finances itself with a lot of
conferences and in this case not a lot
of them are happening
so i do if you have if you are able to
please do donate to no focus
we do have a code of conduct so uh
it's it's essentially you can read the
code of conduct and this is the pi data
code of conduct but in in essence it's
just it's
basically says that you have to behave
professionally
uh for any code of conduct violations or
anything you would like to tell us
please contact us in the meetup or you
can also contact
leonie merk which is
someone who is independent from the
organizers
who is a member a member of a committee
in noon focus
okay so before we go to on sponsors i
wanted to do a bit of uh
interact and then to try out a bit of an
interactive
[Music]
presentation so i would like to launch a
poll and please vote and let me know
uh if you're a first time attendee and
what is your background
i'll i'll keep the poll on for one
minute
and see if people can vote and get a bit
of a feeling
i i have a feeling that our virtual
meetups
um makeup of assist as a
makeup of people who are assisting is a
bit different from our
in-person meetup
cool so i'll leave it a bit more maybe
you can get a bit more answers
um wait for a bit
okay almost almost done almost done
i think the panelists can also reply if
they want to
so i'm gonna end the poll in
one two three two one
cool so if you're interested here's the
results so it seems like a lot of people
are
our first time attendees uh so
welcome everyone who's the first time
item d it seems like most of you are
either data scientists or develop
developers which is actually quite
a normal thing in the pi data network
it seems it seems like conferences get
more senior leadership
too but i would assume yeah maybe maybe
uh
for a meet up senior leadership have too
little time but they only go for
conferences
well this is really interesting i'll
keep it
uh i'm gonna take a bit of a picture of
it and see
uh thank you and and well i wanna
want to thank our sponsors which uh
which in the past would be
paying for pizza uh in the case of
raspberry pi hosting us in their
in their in their headquarters uh but in
this case
well it's difficult uh to do pizza
obviously
but this is still the companies are
helping us
keep this meetup running and sometimes
pay for some expenses for speakers when
they travel obviously there's no
traveling right now
so we do have a job board for different
uh
sponsors so i am a data scientist at
arms so
if you want to talk about any of these
positions you can speak to me
and essentially the first job in this
job board is from our team
so my team so it's a data sciences
position but there's other positions
like machine learning
system analysis engineer staff
performance analysis engineer principal
data engineer so please please let me
know
if you want to speak about any of these
fetch ai we have two speakers from fetch
ai so i'm i think they would be happy to
speak to you
uh if if you want to know anything more
so yeah they have a range of positions
like devops engineer software engineer
machine learning scientists and
engineers web developer
etc but if you want to know more
obviously this this talk
soon will tell you more about what they
do
uh there's also updates in the pi data
network there's the pi data global
which is happening in the 11th of
november to the 15th
so then since there's no pi data
conferences there's going to be this
point data
global the call for proposals is already
closed
but please do consider attending uh
this kind of conf online conference
so i've said a lot please contact us uh
one of the reasons is that we are always
looking for speakers if you know someone
uh who would like to speak in our meetup
uh please let us know if you'd like to
speak yourself
we are always happy to arrange this and
we are always
like we're also looking for sponsors um
it's it's it's
running this meetup right now it does
not have a lot of costs
but we hope to to go back to physical
meetups soon
and that with that comes a lot of cost
if we want to offer people uh pizza and
drinks and if we want to pay for
speakers to travel from other parts of
the uk
please follow us on twitter on pi data
cambridge at pi data cambridge and
please
email us for anything about code of
conduct
if you want to contact me about any
other jobs or
any other contact for you any other
reason you want to contact anyone from
our
organizing committee please write to us
in
in the email by data cambridge
and that's it for me so let's get this
started
so i'm going to stop sharing and
josh or iris i don't know who's starting
but you can start
yeah it's with ours hey guys um i'll
introduce
to introduce us i'm josh application
lead at fetch ai and i'm joined by aris
one of our senior software engineers
we're part of the applications team so
we're building agent
multi-agent systems on top of the fetch
ai um
infrastructure that we're building so
fetch ai
uh is uh building a a blockchain
and a little bit more so if i take what
we're what we're building from
from the from the front from our web
page and especially
is building an open access tokenized
decentralized machine learning network
to enable smart infrastructure built
around a decentralized digital economy
now what this means is fetch is building
a is building a blockchain ledger
which enables machine learning at the
nodes and in the smart contracts
and on top of that we're building a
smart infrastructure which is an
agent-based multi-agent system
that enables us to bring some form of
digital economy
to individual entities that are
represented by agents
and the agents what me and aris will be
talking about this afternoon
over to you aris
so yeah i'm going to demonstrate
the trains demo
uh and yeah my name is arsenal strz
i'm software engineering at fetch ai as
tools preset and
yeah we're demonstrating the
decentralized train demo
this is the link for the video that we
uploaded uh some weeks ago
and uh yeah so what's
what is it about this project uh this
project collects a huge amount of data
from uh different apis and
uh we distribute this data in different
agents
you can see this uh uh this front end
this is a tool that we built in order to
debug
and visualize our trains
so uh how we get the data we are working
in the uk and uh
for that reason we have access to this
to nasa
to these two apis the national rail api
and the network api both of
these apis are letting us get updates
for train creations cancellations and
movements and also
for the boards for the stations and this
enables us
to accurately position every single
train in the uk
on real-time basis you can see we can
get details like the operator name
or the platform or the time of departure
in this case
and let's talk about the whole
architecture of the system
the whole project is uh built around the
agent framework
that we built in the set ai
so we have i'm going to explain a little
bit more about this system
in a later site
slide but for now we have we you can see
that we have
three entities uh that communicate with
each other and then we have a standalone
peer node and uh the sof
yeah i missed something anyway
uh so the whole concept is that we are
going
to have all the agents running on the
sof so we are able to
discover them negotiate with them
and finally transact so how this is
works
let me find out yeah
nope i'm missing a slide anyway the
agent manager
actually communicates with the pool
manager to take
to get a fresh agent a pre-built agent
so we don't lose time
to create them on the fly then the agent
manager runs the agent
and then via the multiplexer sends a
message
to that agent to update
their data
the key here actually is we are using
the peer-to-peer
agent this is a standalone
aaa framework agent that enables us to
connect all the agents and the
multiplexer of the agent manager
as clients to that node and therefore we
can actually
exchange messages with this agent
so the base concept as i said before
is to find the agents to be able to
communicate with his agents
negotiate with his agents and finally
transact
for that reason we are actually create
a client agent these client agents
enable us to search the
oes node for possible
sellers the the sellers in this
situation are the trains and the
stations
and they're selling data uh
about the position of the train if
if the train is late or on time and
for the stations they sell actually the
boards we are searching in a radius of
50 kilometers around
the client and then we transact
with this uh with with
with the agent that uh we can find so at
this point i think i
can do a live presentation
if i find the correct
that's it so we are running the period
node here
and then we are going to run the agent
manager
this is going to create all the agents
we want
to publishing the network and connect to
the period node
give it a minute
so we're creating the pools and then you
in a minute you will see that we are
receiving messages and we are
creating agents so these are the
messages that we are receiving and
sending
to the agents and
we can actually verify that we are
having agents
by going to the sof
site here and check that the number here
is getting up
so since we have our agents running and
getting details
we are going to run our client agent
this client agent is going to
search in a specific location uh 30 or
50 kilometers around it
and buy all the data from the stations
and
the trains that we can find sometimes
takes one or two minutes to find
a possible agent
so yeah you will give me
that
the other part that i can show you until
we get an agent is
once we have a transaction we will be
able to see
the transaction uh in the agent one
this is the cosmos ledger
that we have in hai
so we found two agents and
what happened here we found two agents
and then we are sending an sfp
we are getting we are accepting the
proposal and
we are paying for this data
and once we have the transaction
completed and
we and uh the train agent or the station
agent
verifies that we got the tokens
we are sharing our data in this case we
have
a tray agent type tray
with all the details that we need and
similar here and we
keep looping here until we stop it
and if we refresh this page you can see
that 22 seconds ago we did a transaction
on cosmos ledger so
actually this is the trains project
thank you very much and i think josh can
take over from here
yeah thanks iris
no way i'm trying my best to figure this
out
um let me share my screen all right
there we go
so i'm gonna just rush us over to to
here
so can you hear me okay you can see i'm
shooting that's fine
yeah that looks good excellent so yeah
i'd like to introduce the
decentralized delivery network uh this
is uh quite a
large project comprising a multiple
parts so this presentation's
mainly on the connectivity of agents and
the protocol defined to
allow multiple agents to communicate
using one set of standards
so before i go into the overall details
i'm just going to take you to like a web
view of what's what's happening
so this is running a simulation and you
can see
these grey dots are effectively drivers
going to a passenger to pick them up
these passengers and drivers have found
each other over the
over the pitiful network and they're
registered on the simple oef
i'm going to get ahead of myself here
and introduce these a bit too early but
the the
oef effectively is um where agents would
register so if you can think of that as
a search engine for agents
and the peer-to-peer network is how
agents communicate with each other
so these these tax even drivers are the
drivers and passengers are kind of
finding each other and
doing a journey and i'll i'll kind of
flip back to this as i explain things as
we go through the project
so the centralized delivery network this
is designed to give
an individual in the gig economy
autonomy so the idea is that you're a
driver for any of the ride sharing apps
if you're a delivery person for any of
the food delivery services you can
effectively stop working for those
services
or at least reform at how they work and
have a lot of control over over how you
work and you can
in this way with an agent representing
you can effectively
um negotiate with with restaurants with
people with passengers about how much it
would take and how much it would cost
for your
services and how long it would take for
you to get to them the agents are built
using the agent framework something that
aaron mentioned earlier we mentioned at
the
presentation the agent framework is a
python library that you can download and
build on top of
to build agents to form multi-agent
systems that can connect with fetch air
fetch ai agents but any agents that
you're building at that time
the project uses a specialized
negotiation protocol which is the ddn
this using this enables drivers to
deliver people
packages and food
what i've shown you is an mvp
it's controlled by simulation so
effectively there is a
simulation class in the background
that's controlling the agent's position
and affecting
over overall state now that could be
whether or not a passenger thinks a fare
is too much money
it could be whether or not a driver
decides to take a 10 minute break
or just general how much a passenger or
driver would like
to spend or be beware out they would
like to be
so continuing um so the core ideas um
and i think i think this is just uh good
to kind of reinforce because i'm not
entirely sure everyone knows
who fetch ai fetch and ai are so um the
agent framework
as i've said is a python package and we
we use it to build multi-agent systems
all of the applications that we build in
fetch ai will use the agent framework
when when building agents we're using
blockchains
our own and ethereum and others we use
smart contracts
and if you're not aware of what smart
contracts are in the highest
level sense i like to think these as
predetermined immutable rules
somewhere online that we call and get a
response we can
update them sometimes too the system
that the ddn is a system that gives
gains for independent people
it effectively connects entities and
these entities can be
cars can be people can be products and
represents
them as agents these agents can be very
intelligent they can just be
quite simply returning the day at day
and time
the agents are fully customizable and
and they run with very little overhead
um they can run on your phone or watch
providing that they
meet protocols to connect with our
agents and finally an agent really could
take up a whole data center
if it was doing any form of prediction
modeling for weather
so from there i introduced the
architecture now
i i realize this is going to be quite
small on your screen so i've got it um
in another
image to the side this side here we go
so the the ddn is kind of comprised of
two
individual parts we've got the
centralized layer and we've got the
decentralized
layer so the centralized layer is not
something that i want to spend too much
time with
but to get lots of decentralized
entities
information onto a web page we have to
have a message
cert message passing server basically
and a way to get into a web page
so we're using kafka because it's very
good at handling vast amounts of
messages
we then kind of pass that and feed that
out to web pages that connect to it
on the decentralized side which is
basically how the agents
where the agents live we've got the
agents uh we've got their communications
to the peer and the soef and finally
we've got their connections to
the blockchains where we're mentioning
fetch i interfere in another
so to break down what these parts are
individually the
the peer to peer layer where the agent
agents
talk to each other the oef layer here
simple oef
handles registration and search and then
finally um bottom left
the blockchains are recording
transactions and could be where smart
contracts are
have been deployed to so
the agent itself is comprised of four
core parts
um there could be more depending on your
agents but for us
we have a connections contract contracts
protocol and skills
class so the connection class of the
agent effect
it manages the connections to the
peer-to-peer layer
connections to kafka to update its state
to the front end and finally the
connection to the simple oef
the connection only controls the
connection so it doesn't have
any for any logic that would control
data coming through or just effectively
take
um a message from the skill layer and
send a message to the skill layer it's
very very very singular what it does
additionally we've got the the contracts
uh class
which handles uh the interfaces and
contracts
to a blockchain this is where
um your agent would say would would
you can download these these contracts
from from our repos
and deploy them within the agent and
such
um and the agent will effectively have a
reference to these contracts
and then deploy them into for whatever
use they may have so in our case we use
an escrow contract
which i'll explain a little bit more in
the next slide and
that kind of manages um the payment and
negative payments
between a driver and a passenger
then we've got the protocol and this
effectively defines how
uh drivers passengers food and
well yeah drivers passengers food
parcels will communicate with one
another
so kafka is um defined so that we always
send the same message structure to
to uh kafka location is defined because
that's
the simulation basically needs to always
be sending
the right data across across the project
and then taxi
is um now known as the ddn and the
the ddn defines how a passenger would
um talk uh to the driver and the driver
would talk to the passenger
finally the passenger had the attack the
agent has a skill class
um this manager's core logic of the
agent so we've got the identity
um which you would think of as
in our case we're we've got a proof of
identity but
in a driver's sense they might have a
carriage license um
perhaps scans of any kind of
identification um
a unique uh public address for each
blockchain
and um yeah that basically additionally
it will have
skill like um logic that would say if i
was a driver but i only
i drive a very fancy mercedes so i only
want to take jobs
that are over 100 pounds or
whatever digital currency using at the
time that that kind of logic would be in
there and that would filter out the
messages that come through the
connection to
to um to align with that strategy
additionally we have a database um this
database is
pretty essential for uh localized
history
and then eventually this will this ties
into our
machine learning um
strategy within fetch ai so this data
can be
uniquely um
used in a privacy providing preserving
manner to effect to
update pricing across multiple drivers
for example
and then finally we have a class which
is simulation which
i really isn't uh very very important
for this agent but the simulation uh
manages the taxi
and the state of the system as i've
already described
um continuing uh the as i've mentioned
before here that
our protocol for the ddn is how this
the system works the protocol is
best defined in this one-way system
and if i go over to here i can i can
probably
talk about this and iterate through but
when a
when a passenger uh connects uh
it sends a call for proposal to the
network and this is uh propagated
through the network with the psp layer
if you're a driver that's it looking for
this message you will see this
proposal come through and in green here
you will actually know your quest
this quest request will probably ask for
more information but it's not always
essential
then the passenger will respond and if i
can just zoom in here a little bit
this response will say to the driver do
i or do i not want this
um this journey the driver here can
decline
and in this in these first four kind of
actions this is where the core
negotiation will take place and the
request the request and response can
iterate
almost indefinitely until one of the
agents decides within its skill that
it will only negotiate to say 10 layers
um
whether or not the the journey will
continue
so if the journey does continue uh after
the response
the the taxi driver will send
a proposal to the passenger
so in this example we assume it accepts
but if it doesn't accept this would a
proposal could then be followed up by
decline and the decline
has a valid response as they call for a
proposal and it erases back on itself
this is it's actually more of a graph of
communication than it is this
this one-way system that i'm showing
so if the proposal is accepted um at
this point
the passenger will send the driver and
accept and the ex
the driver in return will send a
contract
address where the passenger is to send
funds for the for the journey so
when the passenger sends funds the
driver will check for a deposit and then
the driver will start to send updates
once the the funds have been verified
so what what what is happening there is
there is a contract are deployed on the
blockchain that the driver owns
additionally the driver is not the only
owner there is a dispute resolution
owner
and this contract will state
the agreed amount between the passenger
and driver
and at the end of the journey if the
journey was fine the passenger will
effectively well the passenger can
release the funds or the passenger can
time out
and like after so many block
confirmations the passenger the funds
would be released automatically
if for any reason there is um
a problem with the with the journey and
the passengers just
the driver perhaps the driver hasn't
turned up or the passenger says stop
midway through the journey and the
passenger doesn't want to release funds
and makes that clear
the dispute resolution service can come
in which is another agent
and can calculate um how far through the
journey
the the journey was so to do that there
is
a proof of location concept in the
project where
at each point um say every 20 seconds
the driver and passenger will do a
handshake at a
certain location and agree that they are
there and this is all happening in
in after the pickup sorry but this
relates to the contract
um this this will then be signed to the
to the uh contract and then you will
have a a a small history within
within the contract that says i got so
far through the journey
and then based on the rate that's been
defined for the journey the
dispute resolution agent can effectively
divvy up
funds at that point so the contract's
quite specialized for the for the ddn
but we're we're constantly changing this
and
running new simulations simulations on
how these contracts can work
so to go back the the funds have been
deposited to the contract
and now the driver is updating the
passenger to say i am on my way to
collect you or i'll be there in two
hours or they might not say anything
because
the journey's the next day when it comes
close to picking them up they'll say
you know i'm on my way and then
eventually they'll say i'm outside your
house i'm here to pick you up or outside
wherever
at that point they'll handshake to say
they're in the car and that that goes
back to the logic i was talking about
where the driver and passenger agree
they are
um in the car so now they're now they're
agreeing that they're moving
and this will be happening and well when
this
driver here picks up a passenger they'll
be sending this
update to every uh to the contract to
say they are where they
agree they are so going back
um once the handshake's been made when
they get to their drop-off location the
driver
and passenger agree that this is the
drop-off point they'll handshake again
and then the front then the journey will
be complete at this point
the complete will end the loop for the
passenger but the driver
will have been continuously in this
corporate proposal proposal loop
building up the next journey the next
journey and the next journey best
best fitting for their schedule and this
this could change
quite often but they're going to be
choosing their best bit based on where
they are so it will almost
almost always be the closest journey so
the gap isn't as far
or it could be the the best price um but
we're we're constantly changing this so
we're you know that
we're um yeah we're simulating to work
out what could be the best
um financial interest for drivers in
this situation
um with with the journey complete we
will
if the passenger doesn't release funds
as i mentioned earlier there's a timeout
in the contract that would release
defense to the driver
okay so let's go back to the
presentation
so that actually was as far as i wanted
to cover with it with
with the with the ddn um i'll just show
you
a snippet of code because we we haven't
planned to show too much but this is
quite interesting
um we have the uh protocol specification
here for what i've been talking about
which is the ddm protocol
and we have in the agent framework
a command that can generate effect all
of the code that runs for the protocol
from a simple definition and this this
kind of shows the idea where i describe
that we're
we're communicating across a bunch of
nodes and uh
vertices uh edges so the idea is that in
the beginning
a passenger will send a call for
proposal and that will that can only be
met with a request
for more information a decline or an
update
um a request can only be met with a
response or an update
and then as we go through it a journey
complete for example can only be
responded to by a release or an update
uh and that
that is effectively how we're building
the the project and that's the protocol
and as we as we develop this this does
have a lot of extra bits in here that we
haven't shown
like at collection point at drop-off
point um
this this is tying into our
parcel collection and delivery which
which we do have working but the
develop branch is a dangerous branch at
the moment um so
i can't really show that but the idea is
that a driver
if economically viable and they don't
have many journeys
up to a point they can choose to pick up
parcels on behalf of parcel
delivery companies and then you know
schedule in to drop that off at a
uh depot based on the journeys that are
coming up in the future
with that i'll um just go back to the
the slides um and show
it's still still going so this there'll
be negotiations happening between the
drivers that are in gray
um and passengers and and honestly with
with
um a certain amount of round and
intervals of um
of negotiation it can take a little
while for for the drivers to find the
passengers
well they've found them to agree with
passengers
and yes so
presentation uh with that that kind of
concludes uh everything i want to share
with the ddn
uh as mentioned earlier we we have a
range of uh option
um opportunities at fetch ai uh we're
looking for
devops software machine learning and web
engineers we're
looking for a front end developer and if
you're keen
in the room where the applications team
is definitely looking for a python
developer you join me in arrows working
on this uh we're looking for a marketing
and partnership manager
community manager and social media and
content executive
uh you welcome to ask me questions or
just email
careers at fetch ai and that's that's
everything from us
thanks joshua um if anyone has any
questions please
put them in the q a and we will start
answering them uh to start it off
i have some questions that might be a
bit uh
silly but let's see how it goes so um
so when i get into you know taxi and and
you know you might say when where i am
through location services but the moment
i stepped into it
i tend to turn off my location kind of
saying i don't want to
waste my battery so you did mention that
there's like a handshake saying you know
every 20 seconds of where we are
would that have a would that be a
problem and this might will my
my behavior be a problem your behavior
your behavior would be a problem
so you you wouldn't have to so as a
passenger you wouldn't you you could
avoid
any any contract with a dispute
resolution you could just say i'm going
to pay these funds i don't want any
smart contract i'm going to pay when
they get here or pay when they drop me
off and some drivers will be okay with
that
we're effectively in some ways over
engineering this and
trying to create a a
what we described as a fair system that
benefits both the driver and the
passenger
but um yeah there is
realistically no no hard rule that you
need your
um location on yeah well it does make me
think uh
if it's a problem in in the current
services right now maybe i'm
i don't have proof of where i was
um uh the other quick question i had uh
uh was the you did mention a little bit
about
how you solve those requests and it's
about a price or a journey is that
in the uh the uh uh
where is that logic is it part of the
so that's that's part of your skill and
effectively
there's a couple of parts this and it
can be as complicated as you want to be
but we have a like a yaml file where you
can just
um you can imagine that this would be
represented in a web page where you just
fill in a few boxes and say what your
preferences are in an app
and then they would be filtered through
and the agent would find and search
by that and yeah that that it's all
happening within the skill once the
message is passed to it from the
connection layer
uh the the decisions are made in
in the asian school cool yeah those were
my questions
um does anyone else have any questions
um
i i would welcome to questions from many
of the panelists
if you want to
hi guys sure and that was great
presentation thanks josh naris i guess
when it comes to blockchain a lot of the
benefits are around the sort of threat
modeling so decentralization means
less points of weakness um you don't
have to trust a single entity
that being said um and obviously you can
answer this as freely as or not
but where would you see the sort of um
not the weaknesses but if you were
trying
if you're a malicious actor i suppose
how would you approach a decentralized
system like this
okay yeah there are so everything i say
we're combating
readily but you you as a driver
could say you could approve a job
and in the current system you could say
that my rate is
a certain price and then if
you didn't turn up or you did turn up
and drive off you could
if you could uh still get paid the
the journey to get to that position if
that makes sense you could just drive
around getting positions never let
anyone in your car
uh that loophole won't exist in
in a few months time i'm sure but right
now that that is there
uh we we have introduced the concept of
trust
and i haven't talked about that in this
in this in this presentation
but there are it's not the art it's not
the
goal of the oef or the layer to monitor
transactions that go through at certain
stages
so a secondary set of agents are
monitoring
all transactions that are going through
the chain and then looking for
ones that have ended early um and you
can do you can do that by just checking
the the contract to see um because it'll
be publicly available a lot of these
variables
um what what uh contracts may have ended
earlier than necessary and you'll start
to see a pattern if a driver started
ending uh journeys you know very early
on
they'll start to become a slightly
untrusted member of the of the pool as
such
uh but there's a lot of work to be done
there um on trust in
a decentralized system and
some things we we've not solved um
like like i've mentioned uh but that's
some of the more interesting parts of
this that's for sure
thank you so there's uh two questions in
the q a
i'll read out one so might be a silly
question
but is fetch ai just developing the
software or are you yourself
looking to be the company that taxis and
drivers registered to
uh yeah and apologies if it was covered
in the first five minutes that
they missed good question we're building
the software um and we're building the
framework to
enable other companies to build the
software to connect with this as well
too
um so i i would say right now we're
building the software because to prove
it can be done and proving that we're
thinking about how this all ties
together in a centralized manner
but um from there we're open to
speaking with a lot of companies at this
point um we're we're in talks with with
lots of lots of projects lots of
interesting projects
and um yeah that's that's i think that's
certainly going to sign that one
cool so there's one more question um
do the drivers have the ability to
compete for a transaction at all
say if a second driver were a further
distance from the passenger but there
was only one available job in the area
i think it's kind of related to my
request question like where does that
logic exist and can you as uh as a
driver play with it in a way
yes there's a couple of things here um
when the
drive when the passenger um does a
request
uh two drivers will get that
simultaneously and if they're
say 10 seconds late to to the request
they'll still get it will still be
propagated through the network
um to to the two drivers now
the passenger could say i will only
um i will wait 20 seconds for all
responses and then i will choose the
best out of those 20 seconds
um and if they do that they will they
will choose their best fit out
at that pool but if they're willing to
wait longer
um two agents they will they will they
will negotiate with each other
and one of these taxis will say i will
get to you
sooner or i will be cheaper and then the
passengers preference
will pick now there's nothing stopping
the passenger from still looking for
this journey even if they've agreed the
journey with another driver and the
driver comes to them
but if that happens the passenger is
going to lose
uh most likely that base fee for that
driver coming to them
now that that that idea is coming from
the
from the uh uber model that we see now
we can
we've used but if you were to look at um
other taxi
companies that you can book a book a
driver throw
through that that logic doesn't
necessarily exist so
this is going to come down to a lot of
uh
i want to say behavioral science um
and things that i'm not necessarily a
specialist in to to kind of work with
how
how people will behave the idea that
they have to follow through with a
booking for example
and or um counseling you know what the
implications of that are
right thanks so that that's all the
questions there's just one tiny one
is if you're gonna share your slides but
if you if you want to share your slides
we can definitely coordinate
after the meetups for that well then
that's it thank you very much
josh and eris
um and now we'll we'll let amadeus give
his talk
we can have a tiny little break whilst
the madeira sets up
great thanks everyone and thanks again
josh naris really interesting
um my my the question which will segue
into this talk is
you know when you're looking at data
from let's say the train network
and obviously those are physical devices
hurtling around and where does that data
come from it's great they have an api
but what lies behind that api
so obviously my answer is iot internet
of things and which is what i'm going to
cover
today and just quick background before i
start and i'm the head of product at
decoded we're a
tech education company so we run
enterprise programs around data literacy
leadership teams and we run data skills
programs for fledgling uh
data scientists so and very much
education is the core of what we do
and before i worked to decode it i
did my phd in nanotechnology and i
actually shared an office with
fedex um so thanks very for having me on
um
our paths have diverged somewhat but
i'll bring it back to arm at the end
um so i'm gonna share my screen and um
this
is very much not a work talk this
is the result of what is essentially a
lockdown project so
um it might be uh a tad less not
professional hopefully but
um still uh polite but um very much sort
of a fun project so
the goal of this talk is to convince you
all that um data cleaning and
modeling and engineering isn't the
hardest part actually getting the data
in the first place is especially when it
comes to internet of things
the motivation for this project actually
started about
two years ago and i was living in the us
i was heading up the us team
educated for five years and my wife and
i decided to move back to beautiful
north yorkshire
um so we were living in the north of
england in a very rural setting
and um as any um
uh northerner knows winter's coming it's
cold
so we need to do something about the
heating and actually when you look at
sort of
mean temperature values across the
country obviously blue cold
red hot cambridge in the middle um it's
pretty cold up north although
technically the north of england is
actually about halfway up
the uk so it's not really the north but
i'll get in trouble if i say that to a
proper northerner
so what did we inherit well this is a
slightly terrifying looking 1982
kid oil fired boiler running off
kerosene heating oil
and it's a bit of a breed you switch it
on and it
absolutely um gobbles up oil and we've
got mixed fuel stoves i'm not going to
be automating that
and we've got classic electric heaters
and combi boilers as well as a few other
bits involved
so i'm working in a very mixed fuel
environment and the motivation for this
sort of project was primarily to reduce
our environmental footprint so
how do we reduce carbon emissions lessen
our dependency on those
um but also actually have hot living
conditions
um don't want to live in a 10 degree
house and part of that also reducing
costs but but also for me technical
stretch
um so the aim of this sort of project
which is ongoing
was to build a highly efficient
battery-powered thermostat driven
climate control system or to retrofit
antique inefficient heating systems with
the latest and greatest
in iot technology so when i say iot
internet of things
it's great because it could be pretty
much anything you can connect cars
trains as we saw um phone solar panel
power plants whatever you want it's a
very broad concept around connecting
inputs and outputs
so to start with um i needed a platform
and i
actually registered for an account on
reddit which i'd never registered for
and i said hey what does everyone use
and and this
great open source um python based
raspberry pi
uh compatible um software project called
home assistant
and if you've used home assistant or use
it um be great to just drop a note in
the chat
i'm always curious to see who's using it
but essentially it's
a pip install um you run it on a local
server and you get this sort of
interface so it's pretty basic to start
with
and you get sort of things like weather
out of the box based on location
but it's pretty much a blank slate so
this is the platform running on
a little nook actually in my case let's
give it a bit of extra juice
so as you can see in the photo you can
have inputs
and you can track people which i don't
do you can switch lights on and off
um but i wanted to start with some
outputs
so um you can find all kinds of smart
plugs
these are relatively cheap ones by
sonoff um and the idea is you plug them
in connect them to wi-fi using the app
um but i don't want to use the app i
want to use home assistant so
if you go through all of the
documentation you can integrate it but
the integration
involves you sharing your vendor login
to home assistant and basically what
that means is your data goes up into the
cloud somewhere you've no idea where
and then the cloud is controlling your
sort of 240 volt system so
i didn't feel very comfortable with the
idea that i was putting
my data out there in the cloud and in
theory someone could potentially
manipulate that so i opened up this
device
so this is one of the smart plugs and
this thing in the middle here
this is called an esp8266 and
it's chip which turns out it's very
common it's been a really big
chip in the sort of home automation
scene
and somebody's actually done a die cut
so what they've done is they've
literally just chopped off the top of
the chip
and taken a microscope to just
investigate what's inside and it
actually has a bunch of different
like neat things and it's got the sort
of rx and tx components of the
wi-fi network it implements a full tcp
stack so um you can just run um
you know web whatever you want directly
on this
and all of these sort of little things
are um
memory so all of this stuff here is
program memory
and there's a separate flash chip as
well so you can actually store data so
it's an amazing sort of single chip
solution
that allows you to do some pretty cool
stuff so how do you get your software
not the manufacturer's software onto
this chip again the community
is fantastic um this is a project called
tasmota
and so what they do is they've built an
open source firmware so
um hardware is the physical stuff
software is the code
firmware is in the middle it's the code
that you then install
onto the hardware and the reason it's
firm is you can change it but it's a bit
harder
so it's not as easy as writing code you
need to flash you need to transfer
which in and of itself isn't always that
straightforward so how does something
like
um uh a sonar plug work with tesmota
well it's great
they support a whole bunch of devices
and they've got templates and
all the inputs and outputs the slight
snag becomes how do you then
put your firmware onto it so this is
where you need to break out the
soldering iron things get a little
gnarly
you're working with these really tiny
tiny connections here this is a
i can tell you these are absolutely tiny
wires and then once you've done that you
plug it into your computer and you flash
it
so i'm not too unfazed by this and this
is my home version
obviously i'm not plugging this into
mains while i'm doing this but you just
have a usb
adapter uh it's called an ftdi it's one
of the common chips
you overwrite it and and there you have
it so then you have your own
tasmotor plug and the way it works is
that the plug
itself um is sort of here so that's the
smart plug
and then the electric heater in this
case
sits on top of it so essentially it's a
power proxy controlled by wi-fi
really it's a fancy relay um so let's
have a look at i'll just show you a live
um sort of version of what that looks
like again um tasmania works on
the web so your local network so i don't
have to worry my threat model is people
outside my house not inside my house
so it's just running on the local area
network and you can toggle it on and off
i don't know i can hear my heating
turning on and off and you can do a
bunch of stuff in here
this um in turn communicates via
something called mqtt
which is a message breaker and again
super easy you run it on a local server
and you define a topic and it's sort of
almost plug and play
and so that's sort of what that looks
like um
once you've done this for a simple plug
you can get a little bit more fancy and
slightly
non-regulation this was um this used to
be a mechanical
controller for the big oil boiler so i
sort of ripped it off and i rewired it
with a different type of sewn-off plug
and i do need to cover this and there
are lots of electrical regulations that
you should definitely get someone to
check before you do this
and interestingly for a combi boiler
it's sort of similar but um
they actually contain two switches one
is the sort of main switch
the other is the pump to push the hot
water around so you can
switch the boiler on but then you switch
on the pump to access that
so despite being a little nervous about
doing this it's actually worked out
great
and of course this is all going to be
very safe and fireproof one day
so that's what um the uh system
looks like and i think actually if i
just go back
um just to show you how that integrates
you can then add
a little card it's really easy to do you
edit this another card
and now slightly more easily you can
switch on and off so these are the basic
control mechanisms for doing this
and so far everything's pretty um pretty
straightforward
the challenge is of course a lot of
these dumb heating devices whether it's
an oil boiler or
an ac unit or in this case an electric
plug they have very poor thermostatic
control
so um in my case it's just min max what
does that mean in degrees
no idea um there are sorts of standards
on internal temperatures
i'm sure everyone's familiar with 20 or
21 degrees and i'd be interested to hear
what people set their home thermostats
too
um but essentially you need to somehow
figure out how to turn this into
an actual reliable heating device so and
you can build your own sensor network
for that which is basically what i've
done
this is uh something called a dht22
temperature and humidity sensor
and it's actually um despite the number
of pins i think it's a one wire sensor
anyway you buy them for a couple of
pounds on ebay and
you need to hook them up to your own
device now it turns out that there are
lots of different ways you can run your
own chips so this is um a development
board
for uh an esp8266 so this thing here
is uh that's the module it's a 12f so
it's the
the actual chip itself is about this big
and then next to it the ram
and then there's some other bits and
bobs so if you can imagine um you
get these kits where you get the module
the benefit of using these kits is you
can do things like
um you can directly connect with usb it
has a voltage regulator so you don't
have to worry about that
but you should be able to see this is
the antenna um you buy one of these
if anyone's used the arduino it's very
similar and you can sort of control it
like that
so that's great you can plug all that in
and what i'm going to quickly show you
is the sort of logic behind how this
works so
you power up the device you read the
sensors you connect to the wi-fi network
you connect to the mqtt server and you
publish the data
so that in a nutshell is the simplest
approach to
what this looks like all of this stuff's
on github which i'll share the link
later but just to
give you a sense of all you need you
just specify your
wi-fi credentials the address of your
mqtt server
the topics and then reads the
temperature data connect to wi-fi
um publish the temperature and public
humidity so unless it's like four
functional lines of code with some
debugging stuff around it
so it's very straightforward um to get
this working
and once you've done that you can then
add them into your
home assistant so now what you're seeing
is i've got the little badges this is
sort of real-time data and we'll see in
a minute why it's 45 minutes ago
but um you can also get history graphs
so you can sort of check the temperature
the reason it's stepped is because um in
the production code
um i've set some sort of thresholds to
make it more battery efficient
but if you really want to you can get it
to send the data
every second or 10 seconds and you get
much smoother data but anyway
that's what it looks like so it's pretty
neat you've got your inputs you've got
your outputs
controlling anything like this um
manually is obviously a pain we want to
automate that
so and the brilliant thing about um
home assistant is software defined
thermostat control so
here um it's all configured with yaml so
not too dissimilar from some of the
stuff we were looking at before
um you define um the heater
so um this is the device which you're
going to switch on and off
and then you define the sensor so which
specific sensor so you can mix and match
you could put sensors in different
places you can actually combine sensor
data
you can create software data you do
whatever you want it's a really neat
system
you define your mins and max but it's
the target that really matters
so and with a bit of soldering and um a
bit of
sort of patience what you get is a sort
of nest like thermostat here
so this is um apparently it's 20 degrees
which is amazing so i can't show you
this turning on
because my max oh yeah it's got a
0.2 degree differential but basically
it's just like a nest
um you set the set point you switch it
on and automatically switch itself on
and off
and you can get a sense of the history
so it's actually been switching itself
on and off
just a little bit over here but
basically you've turned a really dumb
electric heater into a temperature
controlled
automated thermostat and you can then
enable the thermostat during working
hours
so step one in the voyage to efficiency
completes
but and this is the big buck this is a
wired system
so it's connected by a plug and anyone
who's worked with temperature
or any environmental data will know that
the position is incredibly important if
you
left the sensor on the floor you get a
much colder reading hot air rises
so really what you want to do is ideally
wear the sensor to get a bit crazy but i
popped my sensor underneath my laptop
and you want to get the center as close
as possible to where you want to
experience that temperature
so and i've got a cop downstairs with a
one-year-old in
it's not in the cot it's near it but i
found that by moving that position it
made a big difference to the heat
so as a reminder the aim of this sort of
project was to build
a battery-powered thermostat control
system and this is where
data acquisition gets hard so far it's
pretty straightforward i hope you'll
agree four lines of code
and where things get tricky is when we
try and
run it off a battery so previously i
think i showed
um that there's a sleep between cycles
um but it turns out there are multiple
kinds of sleep the esp8266 chip
have done they've done a really good job
of implementing different types of sleep
um depending on what you need modem
sleep light sleep or deep sleep
the thing that you want to focus on here
is the um the current so
that's the background power consumption
so obviously you can see
it really drops down to micro amps which
is where you want to be
and and deep sleep mode but that means
no wi-fi no clock
no cpu and there is a wake-up
functionality for that
so let's implement um deep sleep
and all you do in the flow is you change
it to um
deep sleep and then off you go so sounds
pretty straightforward great
now all we need to do is get a battery
attach it to our updated code
and up to the races we are well it's not
that simple because actually
um when you look into it um these
devices weren't really
in fact wi-fi is not a battery friendly
thing
turns out that there are various
components on this friendly developer
board
which um draw current no matter what
you're doing even in deep sleep
so there's an onboard voltage regulator
and which
converts it from whatever you give it to
the correct voltage
um there is the serial chip so to get
usb
you need a chip turns out that that's um
drawing um i don't know probably about
200 microamps
so the sort of links that people go to
to
retrofit uh absolutely horrible i'm not
prepared to do that so
that was a sort of dead end and you
can't just rely on soft
hardware sorry to be battery friendly
next step is i've got one of these um
esp-01f modules
i'm going to try and hold this up to the
camera just to show you how small these
things are
so hopefully it will focus eventually
yeah so
you can sort of see you've got the wi-fi
chip
uh you've got the actual esp8266 chip
and then you've got the flash memory
here
this entire thing is smaller than my
thumb so this is a very small chip
and i thought great there's nothing on
here that can draw power so we should be
off to the races
of course challenge um turns out that to
get deep sleep there is one
uh wake up pin which is how these things
work they go to sleep and they listen on
one pin
and if that's triggered and then it will
wake up and they actually left that off
this design for some
extremely strange reason so what people
have done is take extremely small wires
so you can kind of see on the left this
is how thin this wire has to be
and they've sold it it's the edge of
this thing well i invite anyone to try
that on a chip that looks as small as
the one i'm showing
i did try it was terrible i gave up so
uh what does that mean um we still don't
have a chip that we can run off the
battery
well you can actually buy the modules
themselves so i don't
remember but on the dev chip there is a
small module you can buy this and there
really is nothing on this
so that should be how we can attach a
battery off we go
great challenge number seven at this
point um
[Music]
what battery do you use so battery
batteries are fascinating
and there are lots of different battery
technologies and the ones that i'm sure
people are familiar with
are lithium ion so
phones zinc magnesium oxide is actually
alkaline so
um standard disposable batteries and the
other one that's quite
common is nickel cadmium and then if
you've got a car lead acid
each of these chemistries will have a
different voltage range and discharge
profile
and that matters because ultimately um
you've got
a um sort of target voltage for most low
power devices it's 3.3 volts so
which one do you choose how do you
manage that and for
sort of brevity i went with lithium-ion
and in fact i uh
took a leaf out of the old nokia um 331a
playbook
and the classic snake phone they're
they're 3.3 volt battery lithium-ion
batteries sorry they're 4.2 volt lifting
my batteries
are very small i've got one here and you
can buy them on ebay for peanuts
well couple of pounds and my choice for
using one of these
is um it's a such common phone that
they're cheap
so tiny um effective about thousand
milliamps but
um you need to lower that voltage and
standardize the voltage which you do
through something called a voltage
regulator
this is what's called a load dropout
regulator and this will um drop the
voltage
from whatever it is within a certain
range down to whatever you want it to be
and low quiescent just means it has a
low background current
so the idea is to find one of these
regulators which consumes as
little current doing the job all to save
precious battery time
for anyone who's an electronic engineer
on the webinar
and they'll point out that ldas are
terrible for this because
the difference in voltage they dissipate
as heat so anyway we'll get to that
later there are more effective um
controllers for doing this so this is
what it looks like and this is sort of
the first prototype
running off a battery so this is the
lithium-ion battery
that's giving you about 4.2 volts at
full charge and it'll discharge down to
about
three point something and the voltage
regulator
is actually pretty small it's just a
small chip is here over here
so this then provides 3.3 volts here is
the
uh the chip with a few small components
and then here is the
um dht22 sensor so that's sort of
everything together um and um
it's a little bit messy but it's a
prototype we'll look at how we're gonna
continue that later but sort of bob's
your uncle and we're off to the races
however we're not because lithium-ion
batteries um have a really complicated
charging profile
unbeknownst to me um you can't just
unlike a lead acid battery or a nickel
cadmium back you can't just
trickle charge them stick a solar cell
on they have a
different phases of charge one is a
constant current
charge up until a certain current and
then there's a constant voltage charge
and it all has to be very carefully
balanced so that's probably why you read
about warnings about
badly charging lithium-ion batteries
they can go pop and so in order to do
that
you can just find a chip that does this
for you this is just a
the first chip i found on google um and
again
um you've got a standard voltage in
you've got your battery voltage out and
it will handle all of that
the fun thing here is um you can
differentiate between charging and not
and it's a binary output if this is high
then this light will go on nothing will
happen here it's low
the other way goes around so it's clever
use of um sort of pins
everything's very efficient at the sort
of iot level so um here's a picture of
the one i mocked i actually made
just again point out and these chips can
be really small
so you have to have a very steady hands
um a lot of these are surface mount
chips um that's like an led you can kind
of get a sense of the size
but um anyway it's all working so a lot
of effort to get a battery-powered
temperature sensor you could um
separately
just go straight with an alkaline so
alkaline is about 1.5
so times two you've got about three so
actually with a
2aa batteries with no voltage regulator
you can directly power one of these
chips
so a little bit fast and loose but
that's another way this doesn't solve
the environmental problem because this
is non-sustainable you have to throw
these batteries away
rechargeable a batteries won't be
alkaline they'll have a different
voltage threshold you're back in the
same problem
so this is probably about two two months
into the project i get really excited i
load it up drumroll how long does this
system last for
nine miserable days after nine days it
drained the battery completely
um so the the reality is i'm sure many
of you thought
this particular flow is very inefficient
um
every time you publish constantly you're
reading constantly you might sleep
um but what if there's no temperature
change you're still wasting energy
so going back to um yes so sorry going
back to this
how would you store the state of the
previous temperature and
check for a change and before you
connect to the wi-fi connection to the
wi-fi tends to be the most
energy-intensive process
well you need memory to do that and as a
reminder and in deep sleep
you've got no wi-fi no system clock no
cpu clock therefore no access to sort of
memory you've all you've got is a
real-time clock
it turns out the real time clock's roll
is to count
so you put it to sleep for 10 minutes it
needs to store that 10 minutes
somewhere and needs to store the the
counter somewhere as well
so actually you can steal um about 500
bytes
of this real-time clock memory for your
own purposes so it's a bit hacky and
it's quite low level
um but it's possible so what does that
look like
first thing you do now when you power up
and i should just clarify deep sleep
means
go to sleep and when it wakes up it just
reboots
so that's that's the reboot so on reboot
read the real-time clock memory
if it's valid i.e it was um stored then
read the sensors check if there's a
difference and only if there's a
difference connect to the wi-fi and
publish
if it's not valid just read the sentence
connect to wi-fi
so this sort of flow chart um is what uh
i ended up with
and just to give you a flavor of the the
complex
i mean it's still very simple compared
to the stuff we were saying before but
at the you do have to program in in a
lower level language
so this is essentially c and this
shows you this is the 512 bytes you need
to really be careful on the
data types and the amount of memory they
use and also you need to understand
things like
floating point arithmetic and pointers
and i confess i didn't and i've got
luckily
i got a great friend i could call up on
zoom he could help me out so anyway
and this is how you access the real-time
clock and remember this is just
to try and save a little bit of power so
that this device lasts for a bit longer
so we've now got to a point where um we
are efficient and does it work nope
why not because in 2017 there is a
closed issue
um whereby if you use this deep sleep
switching off the radio
there is no way to switch the radio back
on
no way to do that um so that's like a
complete dead end and
turns out that in this long thread um
you can do a whole bunch of stuff uh
anyway i figured it out
and in the spirit of open source i did
manage to um get
any pr merged on their documentation
just to explain how you can do this and
essentially the way that you do this is
more complicated flow charts
and your sort of very limited rounds
running out
you basically um store a bunch of
publishing flags so you store a bunch of
flags which is
has the temperature change and long
story short you have to go from a deep
sleep to a quick deep sleep with rf
enabled and then you it goes through the
whole process again
so it does get a little bit more
complicated um i'm sure
my code could do with refactoring but
now um
you've got to store a lot more
information i mean it's still not a huge
amount of memory
but um you'll you know you have to make
sure everything's four byte aligned
because of the chip design
so it gets a little bit more complex but
it's still only a couple hundred lines
of code
um to do all of this with of course lots
of libraries behind the scenes
so how long does it last about 88 days
and it's still running
so i've got two of these devices one's
lithium-ion powered one's about
a double-a battery powered and i'm very
happy to say they're both running i've
just looked at the clock i've only got
five minutes this is where all the
exciting stuff
happens right so from a data perspective
which is obviously what this is all
about you can store the data and home
assistant with
uh on influx db it's a time series
database
you can bring that in to your notebook
um influx uses sql query
uh bringing the data here you're looking
at three sensors the interpolation is
terrible in matplotlib
and but you can also do some cool stuff
like you can look at
and how often do the how many readings
are you given a day which is essentially
the
rate of change of temperature so um
actually where i'm starting now it seems
to fluctuate a lot you can read into
that what you like you can work out
averages
and you can look at distributions of the
time
uh how long things go to sleep before
they're published say on the whole
between zero and 60 minutes is how long
it will sleep for before it detects a
significant change
and you can also look actually if you
combine this data with when the heating
goes on so that's the blue binary line
you can really see the effectiveness of
your heating system so this is
um how it you can visualize um the
effectiveness of that
and i'll skip through some of this stuff
another thing you can do which i'm doing
right now is i'm
measuring the battery voltage and as you
can see i'm in a sort of linear
regime for two double a batteries that
that should be three nominal
it's actually 3.45 so when you
extrapolate very basically i should get
about 11 months off this thing
which is brilliant i was aiming for six
months but in theory um 11 months so
that's still going on
my next problem i had to solve which i'm
going to speed up now was
um hot water cylinders i don't know you
know this is the kind of thing you do in
down because you're in lockdown but um
oil fired hot water cylinders
typically have electric thermostat
overrides for boosting
those controlled with bi-metallic strips
you can
can't use these sensors they're too big
you can find a smaller sensor this is a
dallas 18b
20 sensor it's actually that small
comparatively you can
solder that together thread it through
one of the thermostats chop off the end
glue gun it together
you can then attach separate sensors
onto the pipes themselves
and wrap it not very effective as we'll
see because you're trying to measure the
internal water temperature
through an external copper bond and it
really isn't a very good bond
so back to um analysis we go
and this is where i think we get a bit
more data
um i'm gonna finish in two two and a
half minutes
so here you're looking at i've got the
inlet and outlet from the
uh oil boiler i've then got the hot
water is measured at the top and i've
got the hot water tube which is the
internal temperature
and basically the name of the gain is to
try and calibrate the difference between
the temperature in the tube which is
more accurate than the temperature on
top
at the moment it looks bi-modal i've no
idea why and if you calculate the diff
and the boiler was serviced halfway
through this chart which is why
you see a jump but there's a 20 degree
ish difference
i might do some time series forecasting
probably not worth the effort i'll take
the average
but um essentially um that's one of the
things you can do and again here you can
sort of see
the impact of switching on the electric
immersion um and the thermostatic effect
as well so basically this is now on a
thermostat
through um that process so to end next
steps
uh you can measure the current really
ain't if you want to to further optimize
really fun stuff you can then once
you've got your sensor design down
you can create your own circuit layout
and your own printed circuit board they
are
and then um just to give you a sense
this is the cool snazzy bit
and this is the that module that you saw
the tiny thing just for scale
this is a double a battery holder so
these things are really small
basically once i've chosen the right
sensors i'll mass manufacture these
if anyone wants one you can ping me and
this is i found another
really tiny temperature sensor it's
three millimeters across
it's absolutely minuscule so i'll
probably use that um in the future
design
but really wi-fi is not designed for low
battery
so you can use uhf these are digital uhf
chips
um and the reason why this is exciting
this is why i get my physics degree
payoff
um is because when you look at the
transmission rate
there is the the the power that you
receive is proportional to the
wavelength
and um as hopefully most of you will
remember the wavelength is inversely
proportional to
um the frequency so long story short
the higher the frequency and the lower
the range so by going low frequency you
increase the range so that's something
i'm going to try with some outdoor
sensors
this is what it looks like this is one
of the chips this is a quarter
wavelength antenna
the next thing is like crazy antenna
design this is a monopole there are
dipoles
this is a whole new world of exploration
which will keep me busy for another
three months
my ending slide is really if you're
interested in this stuff there's no
better way than finding a problem to
solve like your home heating system
because that will keep you through um
all the issues credits wear credits to
you
and i was inspired to do this through
about three years no about 10 years ago
by it's like
nathan he built a whole bunch of small
sensors and
this is now out of date because they
don't make the chips anymore um open
energy monitor is fantastic
um they provide um whole bunches of you
can just buy this stuff as well you
don't have to make it
i just like making stuff and but the
cool thing is a current transformer to
make your not smart meter into smart
meter my very good friend andy bennett
um who helped me
uh with all the c stuff and embedded
device so i'm going to stop there
thank you very much and very happy to
take any questions
oh great stuff um yeah if you have any
questions please put them in the q
a there were a couple of questions for
fetch ai that came late
i'm sure if hey you can write to them
and they will reply
um is there any questions
um i had a bit of a questions do you
have you good have you gotten into any
um
any type of kind of like control control
theory
to to to get your kind of process of
turning on and off the
the heaters you know a bit more optimal
yeah it's it's like the whole pid
control thing um
and to be honest the stuff that i'm
doing is so simple it really is just
trusting the thermostatic control that
they've built within um
the system so you set a target um
i haven't really mucked around with it
beyond that because it's built in
but you could i mean literally
anything's possible
you've got the raw data you can control
the outputs um it's really around what
the problem is you're trying to solve
so give me a hot room new advanced
controlling for that it's more the
placement of the sensor that makes the
biggest difference
there's another question uh did you
investigate
sig b as a low power alternative to
wi-fi
yeah so zigbee um yeah zigbee's
it's on my list um initially i i didn't
go with it because it's sort of
encrypted by nature and i i didn't i
thought that would be a tax on battery
essentially zigbee's gonna be my post uh
diy uhf um job um
it definitely is uh probably a more
friendly version of doing this
um so yeah it's kind of among the world
of
um low energy stuff there's also
something called
loran or loran i can't remember lorin
that's another technology which is
designed specifically for this kind of
application
yes another question have you thought
about it including external
temperature yes actually
um so what let me just go back to
a share quickly i know um it's sort of
dinner time
one of the things that i've done and
i'll just show you
this is a bit more behind the hood you
see into my life
um the central heating
actually is only triggered when
tomorrow's forecast
as the external weather service gives us
is um
less than 10 degrees so you can do some
fun stuff so the night before it checks
tomorrow's weather
and based on that it will switch on the
the heating
and super nerdy it drops me a text by
twilio so i know it's going to come on
cool i think that's it any last
questions before we finally
finish
uh uh frank frank who asked that
question says awesome
so cool all right i think that's it
well thank you everybody thank you
amadeus joshua and iris
and then we'll see you in a month for
our next meetup
thank you very much thanks very much
everybody
thanks a lot